hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning bow it
is and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast Anna I'm just checking
in on you
sorry just seeing how your weeks go and
how everybody's treating you at the
office I hope everything's good I hope
no you know for all you ladies out there
in that toxic male society you know
you're not sitting at your keyboard some
[ __ ] you know some privileged male
comes up and just lays his [ __ ] right on
your shoulder I mean as far as I can
tell that's what's going on out there I
worked in a lot of offices I never saw
anybody with that dick out you know but
you know what that was because I had my
head in the sand but then my ass would
be in the air and there'd be a dick in
my ass at work I don't know I've never
been able to figure it out so anyway I
haven't been doing [ __ ] but working on
the acting gig here I have no idea
what's going on in the world I did see
that Whoopi Goldberg got a little bit of
pushback there was some famous lady and
she took some naked photos of herself
and then she sent him to her boyfriend
via the cellular airwaves there but she
also uses the cloud da when the cloud
got overcast because somebody hacked
into her account saw the photos and then
said hey I got you [ __ ] naked photos
over here why does he have to be Italian
I don't know hey I got you [ __ ] naked
photos over here if you don't give me
[ __ ] five grand and a popsicle I'm
gonna show him to the world so then she
took her power back and she put him out
there I think she's taking her power
back would have been like I'm gonna show
him yeah I don't give a [ __ ] that's what
Madonna would do she took her power back
by by putting him out herself so that
[ __ ] douche could make
any money oh [ __ ] my kids back I've had
to close the door before I start cursing
here mom hang on I gonna take a nap hold
on
I sound back sorry about that yeah
anyways door is closed and dad can
continue cursing here so this is what is
a deal they buy her putting those out
that douche doesn't make any money
that's how she took her power back but
here's my question
alright can't they just find that
[ __ ] person because now that she put
the [ __ ] photos out you know and
she's like I owe you a million hi I'm so
beautiful and everyone can see it's so
hard right like do they not go after
this guy no why am i assuming it's a man
I don't know I'm just assuming that just
seems you know some bald guy with
[ __ ] hair coming out of his ears so
anyway so all this bull [ __ ] goes down
and people are feeling bad for the the
famous beautiful woman with the naked
photos that the guy [ __ ] you know I'm
assuming the ugly male
even if he's good-looking he's felt ugly
on the inside [ __ ] put out there right
so then Whoopi goes basically I'm gonna
paraphrase here which isn't fair to her
but I don't research on this part this
is a podcast people I'm not held to any
sort of standard of [ __ ] quality so
Whoopi basically goes well look you know
that's sad and everything but like what
the [ __ ] you doing is a famous person
sending naked photos of yourself you
just got to know that that [ __ ] is out
there and that could happen don't
[ __ ] send naked photos of yourself
anybody in 2019 if you want to do it she
goes do it with an old-school camera and
frame the [ __ ] but even then someone
could just come up with a cell phone and
take a picture of that so I wouldn't do
that either so she got a bunch of [ __ ]
for that and I was just listening to it
being like that is exactly what the [ __ ]
my mom would have said you know and that
I'm telling I'm gonna do a bit on this
but that it that right there right in
there and she got all his [ __ ] for
saying that you know and then was
sitting there talking about this woman
taking her power
I felt whoopee is empowering the victim
here by giving her the truth and telling
her like a solution don't [ __ ] do
that again and I just think that kids
nowadays they all [ __ ] grow I just
said kid now they I am old and I am 51
I'm officially well into my 50s alright
it's my second year being in my 50s
alright
I've been old since the 90s so I can say
you kids today like the way you were
brought up was just they all listen to
your feelings you expressed your
feelings and they date their solution
was to then be like to yell at the bully
and try to get the bully to stop being a
bully and that literally goes to like
nature where you want to Tiger to stop
acting like a tiger and turn it into a
[ __ ] house cat you can't do it o
people try they bring it into their
house they get wall-to-wall carpet the
Tigers like what the [ __ ] am i walking
on and they think that they're gonna
come in there right and share you know
share their green juice with this
[ __ ] tiger and all of a sudden it's
gonna get on their yoga mat and start
doing [ __ ] downward dog with them it
works for a little while there one day
one day they're a little late with the
[ __ ] 20 pounds of [ __ ] raw red
meat that then and that's it and then
then then you're their dinner alright
bullies are gonna act like bullies
direct there's just shitty kids out
there and there's just shitty people out
there so you have to act accordingly and
it was something that I learned a long
time ago that you have the way you wish
the world was and the way it is and you
have to act accordingly you have to get
on the offensive with the good defense
their defense wins championships and I
won in my generation we grew up they
just like if something happened to you
your parents were like well what the
[ __ ] were you doing there it's [ __ ]
2:00 in the morning you know that's a
bad part of the you know out there
taking your money out what the [ __ ] did
you think was gonna happen
don't [ __ ] do that don't do that you
won't get smashed over the [ __ ] head
my old childhood was blaming the victim
but you know what I learned
definitely suck that could have been you
know I'm not saying my generation my
parents or parents from you know my
generation did it right
but you know there should have been some
more hugs in there they should have been
like well I'm really sorry that happened
to you but what the [ __ ] were you
thinking that you know you could have
had like a little you know little surf
and turf there right but they did they
went then so now there's been like this
over correction where they sit there and
they just [ __ ] listen and listen and
listen and let somebody sob on their
shoulders and like at no point can you
say to the person hey you're in the
public eye don't send pictures of you
[ __ ] Tatas in Yahoo yeah you know
here's another thing like what's
stopping anybody from [ __ ] Apple from
breaking into your little cloud like
they don't know like they're not looking
at all of that [ __ ] you know sitting
there looking at Patrick Swayze's butt
crack he's not alive anymore whatever
the [ __ ] you want to talk about I don't
know I just assumed all of that [ __ ] I
didn't assume it early on with
cellphones but for like the last 10
years you're like oh is that what
they're doing so then you just taper off
you know with whatever you're doing I
still Tex crazy [ __ ] to all my friends
you know I know I think it all comes out
I think you know what it is I don't
honestly unless you get famous or you're
truly going to affect change in a way
that they don't want I think the new
convertible ride to Dallas is they're
just gonna break into your phone and
they're going to just do a search for
certain buzzwords and they will end any
sort of campaign you have four [ __ ]
higher office or cause you have for
reform oh wait so basically what you're
gonna have to be is a perfect person do
you got like your Smart TV whether it
[ __ ] watch and what you're watching
they got a camera up there that they can
look at you these [ __ ]
idiots are now getting that what it was
that [ __ ] hey Siri Siri what color is
the Panda I plan that is back at bite
Thank You theory right and meanwhile
like people are there literally bugging
their own house you got to be able to
say whatever you want in your house you
got to be able to be in your house and
be like my boss is such a [ __ ] god
right you got to get that out of you not
in front of the children
right you got to be able to do that but
I'm telling you like these [ __ ] [ __ ]
are gonna take that information at first
they're just gonna use it for toothpaste
and you know sell you their brand of
[ __ ] whatever but then it's just not
gonna stop there and they're just gonna
keep selling it and sell it and sell it
and sell it and I don't know eventually
it falls into the wrong [ __ ] hands
and all of a sudden you're gonna do
something good you're saving the whales
you're protecting women's rights
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing you're
doing something good and and they're
gonna come in and they're gonna [ __ ]
ruin it they're gonna steer it in the
direction they want to go I feel that's
my thing so I was actually looking up on
the internet because you know when you
get like a laptop you then you can like
put the piece of tape over the over the
camera whatever at this point I'm
assuming that your entire screen can be
turned into a camera if you want to so I
was thinking like and same thing with
your TV even if you put a piece of tape
over the [ __ ] the video camera I was
thinking like they got to have something
where you just like they should have
like this this [ __ ] this screen they
make a screen we cover that you can put
all the way over your entire [ __ ]
flat-screen all the way across your
laptop and then it just plays like you
know that noise that make sure when you
want to fall asleep like the sound of
ocean waves and all of that you just do
that and then you and your wife can
actually have a conversation near your
devices like Pesci and De Niro when
they're walking around covering their
mouth and Casino
or what you do is you have a safe room
in your house with no I phones ITV's or
any of that [ __ ] and you close the door
this is like a sketch and you're just in
the future that's what you're gonna do
you just go in and you have that room
you say whatever you're gonna say
everybody in the house
walks around like they're the Brady
Bunch you know or the perfect family
that Cosby family oh Jesus that's not a
good reference at this point the TV
Cosby family okay what they do in their
personal life is their own business and
the court systems of the United States
that's what they're gonna have like in
the future you know that's what you're
gonna have to do you know but even then
what they're gonna then they're just
gonna have like they'll somehow pass
legislation or just get enough people
addicted to a certain device that needs
to be in every room and then if you
don't have it it's gonna cost you money
in your business and then you're gonna
happen I got to be honest with you like
I there's a lot of things that are
[ __ ] incredible about all of these
devices like I love that moto gp went
off TV but I can still if I didn't have
my laptop and an internet connection I
wouldn't be able to get to watch these
incredible races which by the way I
missed the last race in home Jorge
Lorenzo [ __ ] wiped out some turn Matt
Mauck as his teammate Honda teammate was
in first place he took out Davitt CEO so
he took out Valentino Rossi and I don't
know who the other guy was Cal Crutchlow
I haven't watched yet so I have no idea
who that guy was something on a Suzuki
disc I don't think he'll drive Raja
Suzuki I have no [ __ ] idea to look
all like he was in blitzing one two
three four five he was in fifth place
his teammate was in first and he [ __ ]
wiped out in a turn and caused a domino
effect that took out himself and the
three riders in front of them I would
say that Marc Marquez bought the Lorenzo
a steak dinner that night but I doubt it
because you know they're like jockeys
they got to make sure they day or
they don't eat too much they're all
[ __ ] rail-thin
so there's a lot of stuff about it that
I like but just that whole [ __ ]
spying on people and everything is just
I don't know it's kind of weird that
whole corporate like mentality like you
know they're sitting there talking about
brexit and [ __ ] was saying how that's
gonna have it's gonna present new
opportunities for organized crime you
know to like I don't know bring [ __ ]
into the country and it's just like as
opposed to what as opposed to what legal
organized crime you know what I mean
I guess organized crimes worse because
they actually kill people but soda
corporations corporations will have a
defective car where the gas tank is too
close to the driver and the driver burns
to death and then they'll sit in a room
and do an algorithm and go what's
cheaper changing the design of this car
or just settling the [ __ ] lawsuit and
more times than not they settle the
lawsuit they're [ __ ] murderers you
just right there are committing [ __ ]
murder and nobody says a [ __ ] thing
to him so I don't know you know as far
as I hear from all the older acts and
the older [ __ ] blackjack dealers out
in out in Vegas things were better in
Vegas when organized crime they actually
treated regular people better than these
[ __ ] corporate heartless [ __ ]
constant so I don't know it might not be
the worst thing
it also will make for some good movies
because if you've noticed the mob movie
kind of died because I feel like legal
legalized business stole all their scams
like banking is that's just extortion
that's a loan sharking right
I'm sorry not extortion that's legalized
loan loan sharking the lottery is just
the numbers game that actually African
American organized crime from what I've
seen in movies not like I read about it
came up with in Harlem you know they run
the docks they do the whole [ __ ]
thing they did they just took all their
scams and all the smart mobsters
eventually went legit
like I always heard Citibank was like a
mob bank this is all [ __ ] I've overheard
in bars so don't listen a this [ __ ] but
like if you're a smart [ __ ] criminal
what you're trying to do is take your
[ __ ] and [ __ ] make it legal so
then you don't have to hide the
Lamborghini that you want to buy you can
drive down the street in your
Lamborghini your own politicians in the
cops and all that and they don't have to
[ __ ] and run away from you when you get
pinched you can just be out in the open
with your [ __ ] blood money it's
tremendous I have no idea what I'm
talking about on this podcast I'm just
trying to [ __ ] filibuster here and get
a half hour as I'm doing my laundry I
got a day off from the movie today and
dude I got to tell you man I am
absolutely [ __ ] loved and Staten
Island you know we got to shoot a place
Denis knows pizza and there was a Denis
knows pizza couple towns over for me
when I was growing up different one but
this is like that's one of the legendary
pizza places in Staten Island and then
right across the street is this
legendary Italian ice we shot in both
places I didn't get any of the pizza but
I had a little bit of the Italian ice
and it's just [ __ ] it's beautiful
over there I really I'm really enjoying
it reminds it looks a lot like you know
some of the areas that I grew up in when
I was a kid and just having lived in LA
in New York City essentially for the
last 24 years of my life I miss grass
and trees you know and I miss space
being able to just [ __ ] stretch out a
little bit so I got no complaints about
Staten Island and the few people I've
met out there [ __ ] cooler [ __ ] so who
no oh no the last borough for me to go
to was the most chill you know I'm not
saying it's not upset by I'm sure this
they have their [ __ ] moments all
right every place does especially now
that there's a drug epidemic created by
yeah you know another former suit achill
companies right there's another one they
took all the whole drug game no [ __ ]
drug game it's all [ __ ] legals they
just peddling this [ __ ] out people to
[ __ ] OD in great artists are dying
they're getting everybody hooked on it
they have all their top secret [ __ ]
files none of the politicians can do
anything about it because they're all
getting paid by those
[ __ ] you know oh jesus bill you got on
the tinfoil [ __ ] hat today don't you
yeah I do yeah I do what do you do it's
been raining in the last couple days
so anyway I'm doing my laundry right now
this has taken me back to the days of
being a [ __ ] single man I'm here on
the road doing my laundry and I remember
there was [ __ ] there was nothing that
you dreaded more than doing your [ __ ]
laundry right but there was nothing
better then what once once you secured a
dryer because that was the anxiety
getting a washer you know get the
washing machine and then once you get
out of the wash machine hoping that
there was gonna be a dryer of him once
she had got once you've secured a
[ __ ] dryer there was then it was just
like this is all over this all but it
sucked us back in the day I used to
actually have to wait in the laundry
room and I'd read the papers to papers I
go to the corner I get a little sangwich
there you know be hanging out you know
very rarely would you strike up
conversation here in New York but you
know this place where I'm staying
actually I weighed down in the basement
which is great so I can actually leave I
time it out with my cellphone that's
watching me right now
you know I see it's not all bad little
little little give little take you know
what my laundry's actually be done I got
a hit pause here and what somebody down
there stealing my underwears how do you
hit pause on this [ __ ] thing thought
I hit pause that's not how you do it I
gotta hit stop there's got to be a pause
on this yeah Jesus you know what I
actually decided I'm gonna go old school
here this is the way I used to do my
podcast when I first started out I never
hit pause and I used to call in this
this friggin service have to be quiet
cuz my daughter's sleeping here I'm just
gonna talk to you as I go down to the
laundry room I don't have time to hit
[ __ ] pause so the other day right I
went down they make sure I got my
[ __ ] key I went down to the laundry
room nice [ __ ] [ __ ] it's probably
my neighbor here
[ __ ] took some but I talked about
this right he took somebody else's
[ __ ] laundry out of the goddamn
machine stuck it in the basket I can you
believe that post Harvey Weinstein who
by the way looks like he's gonna get off
write that Asia what's her [ __ ] name
had to [ __ ] recant all her stories or
some [ __ ] no [ __ ] I just see glimpses of
[ __ ] dude how [ __ ] sick is that if
that guy ends up coming back to
Hollywood this is my prediction if he
doesn't go to jail he comes back to
Hollywood he comes back in a blimp just
like like a dark cloud like comes at jet
black and he just glides slowly over the
Hollywood Hills
you know hovering in front of houses of
celebrities that openly you know what's
the word
you know said that they would they would
they didn't like what the [ __ ] he did or
whatever he's gonna come back you know
you got defeated in the beginning that
was like Star Wars and now he's gonna
come back like [ __ ] Empire Strikes
Back alright nice quick elevating you
gotta love a nice quick elevator okay
how are you so can I walk by you know
what he looked like he looked like a
alright this is gonna be now everybody's
looking at me like I got if I'm wearing
a wire here oh I'm an [ __ ] and forgot
my [ __ ] bag and god damnit now I have
to hit pause
all right I'm back he's got my [ __ ]
laundry bag do you know what I was
trying to tell you was a guy walked by
me
you're so funny second you're talking to
a microphone you forget that people can
hear you I'm gonna this guy just look
and he literally heard me go this guy
just looked like and then I remember I
forgot to back the guy looked like Tom
Hamilton accomodation Tom Hamilton from
Aerosmith the bass player and Andy
Warhol um you know I used to not like
Andy Warhol I used to be like this guy's
like the original [ __ ] hipster like
painting soup cans and being like yeah
it's like I don't get it it's a okay
it's a [ __ ] soup can you're
commenting on capitalism all right
whatever kind of got a bunch of [ __ ]
Runaways hanging around well I had no
idea that that guy got like had a
stalker who ended up shooting him and
then like 20 years later he kind of died
from complications of getting shot I was
just like all right like a lot of things
that I [ __ ] on I actually read up a
bottom and I go oh looks like I'm just
the [ __ ] so that's my call Harvey
Weinstein does not go to jail he comes
back in a giant black Zeppelin and he
slowly goes across the Hollywood Hills
you know just pointing you know and he
publicizes that that's how he's coming
back so all the celebrities will be all
[ __ ] shuttering
looking out their windows and he just
[ __ ] points to each one that spoke
out publicly against what he did then
George Lucas brings back the Ewoks and
he somehow gets defeated that's that's
my guess anyway so the laundry's done
it's the best feeling ever
all my clothes are clean that's it
and when you do your laundry you got to
go Nature Boy there right no socks no
wonder where you're going down there
free right that's what you got to do to
make sure they're all [ __ ] clean
because I hate when you come back right
and then everything's clean and then
five seconds later you're done
you showering off the laundry room and
all the [ __ ] Publix crap that you
were just around you know and then
there's an a brand-new pair of [ __ ]
underwear and socks that needs to be
washed drives me up the [ __ ] wall
there you go that's probably a lot more
than you ever needed to know about
[ __ ] but laundry and whatnot all
right what else did I want to talk about
here
sober still sober still [ __ ] throwing
it been laying up the sticks only had
one cigar this week which is good for me
I'm going out tonight with a bunch of
friends so I don't know whatever I was
like smoking I'm almost you know every
other day so you know cutting down there
cutting down you know I don't watch
porno anymore you know I just stopped
doing that I got a brand new laptop
which was great to be able to bring that
over and not have to [ __ ] delete my
entire web browser history but knowing
that they're going to be able to just
[ __ ] go in and see anyways like Jesus
he's watching it almost every day anyway
yeah this thing is smut free I have a
smut free laptop grated I've only owned
it for three weeks but this is the long
as I've gone with a laptop and it's been
smut free and I'm really not ashamed of
anything that I've looked on in the
Internet
that's my new thing this [ __ ]
mustache is driving me crazy
there's a couple of hairs that when they
grow out they won't grow down they're
grow back up into my nose and they
tickle my nose there when I'm trying to
be on stage and tell some [ __ ] jokes
it's really it's really affecting my
time in here so anyway uh but staying in
shape doing all of that type of [ __ ] I'm
just living like this other than [ __ ]
cigars which I really have to lay off
you know I unfortunately get a friend of
mine who's know what's gonna happen I
got to go visit him but uh I don't know
just [ __ ] sick I having to say
goodbye to people I guess that's part of
the eight I don't know it still seems
way too young but anyway let's try to
keep it happy let's try to end the last
oh my how many minutes I got left here
what I got here
c-46 2027 itslef hey let's read some
advertising I got no advertising this
[ __ ] Thursday I don't know what's
going on all of a sudden you know you
say [ __ ] you start talking about jokes
about what Harvey Weinstein in a [ __ ]
black Zeppelin and all of a sudden
there's a problem I mean one of the
highlights of this podcast is let you
know you guys listening to me trying to
try and read out loud isn't it well
wasn't it
so I'm doing a skank fest by the way I'm
doing the goddamn Comedy Jam Sunday
night gonna be playing a song or two and
I'm gonna have a great time doing that
and then also Felicia Collins from the
Letterman band she does this Jam every
Wednesday night I forget where it is and
it's looking like I'm free next week you
never know what the movie business you
never know when you're making one of
them pictures there let me see if I
could find out where that is you should
go see it either way she puts together
like the sickest [ __ ] band ever here
we go Felicia Collins where is it where
is it what's going on Felicia Collins
where the hell is it
I know it's the cutting room is that
what it is no that's March of 2018 I
don't know I'll find it I'll look it up
I'll tweet it out but she does this Jam
it's I think it's in like the east 30s
or something like that I didn't I looked
it up on the internet day I went on the
interweb that I was bitching about let
me see here Felicia Collins jam NYC
Wednesday's right is that how you doing
is that eye you search for something
okay Felicia's jukebox live tickets the
cutting-room New York City is that it
Wednesday June 26 all right there you go
there you go Felicia's jukebox live fel
I CIA Jukes jukebox like eat if I don't
go you obviously should go she has like
the sickest [ __ ] she's a musician
musicians musician
everything is on 10 her guitar playing
her singing her stage president her swag
presence present her prestige presence
her swag the whole [ __ ] thing she's
you she's one of those peoples like you
had to be a rockstar there's nothing
else you could do so she puts together
this sick ass [ __ ] ban because live
music she was saying is leaving New York
City she wanted to you know keep it
going so she has people come down then
she's nice enough to tell me you know I
think they get sick of playing with
great people and they're like you know
what really hone our skills if we played
with a [ __ ] comedian who can barely
play drums if we can actually hold the
song together while he butchers it so
I'll be doing that Wednesday June 26 and
I'll be doing skank fest Sunday night my
old pal Joey roses is going to be on it
Josh Adam maya's is running the whole
[ __ ] thing Nick and the whole band
they're all gonna be down there it's
gonna be a great time definitely check
that out I think that doing two nights
and what else do I have other than that
I just been going around the city been
doing spots oh I got to tell this
[ __ ] story I got a I got a I got a
put together this [ __ ] story right I
got it I got to tell us without [ __ ]
rat anybody out okay so last night you
know I wanted to try out that Whoopi
Goldberg idea that I had that she
reminded me of my mom old-school
parenting and what she said as much as
it came off his mean is old-school
parenting where you're not just coddling
the child you're offering a [ __ ]
solution so I wanted to do that bit and
I got off early enough and I ran over to
Caroline's and Caroline's this show was
over and I was like [ __ ] so there's this
other comedy club around the corner that
I'd never been to and I was like
I was like ah [ __ ] all right I get it
well you gotta figure out what it was
it's the [ __ ] lol Times Square comedy
club so I was like uh [ __ ] it I'll run
over then I'll just do a spot there I
don't give a [ __ ] all he needs a
microphone some people sitting there
listening right they go over the guy at
the door he goes uh what's up I say hey
I'm a comedian thing he goes alright he
lets me in so I never been here so I
don't know anybody there so I come
walking in I got my hat on in my big
stupid orange moustache and uh the guy
come you know I go there's some kid
behind the counter and I just go amen as
the show still going on and he goes yeah
I go can I grab a set real quick I just
want to work out some new stuff he goes
what's your name I said Bill burr and he
looks down he goes you're not on the
list
and I'm like I'm like ah [ __ ] he doesn't
know who I am so now well now what do I
do you know maybe I'll just talk to the
host of cycles well the hosts here can I
talk to the [ __ ] notes cuz I'm not
gonna [ __ ] be like I've been on
comedy I do like it maybe a blend I wake
I was like I'm not doing that so I'm
just alright the host will see me he's
doing stand-up he's in the mix he'll
know who I am maybe I'll give me [ __ ]
ten minutes right the host is
unavailable I go who books the thing I
need to get a set and then the kid looks
at me he goes you want a set or you need
a set and you know I'm not good at math
so I'm like I need a set and he goes I
don't even know what's going on right
now but he just thought it was some
nobody and I was coming in to man at
stage time he's like who is this
arrogant old bald orange from
mustachioed [ __ ] right so it gets
even better is the lady comes out she
goes hi I'm the manager and I'm looking
at her like huh Oh freckles been doing
it almost 30 years
nothing looking at me like I'm some
tourist from Ireland sound like oh my
god you know and I'm tired I got to get
this Senate so she goes I'll give you
the number of the Booker and finally I
just I swear to God I was reduced to
sheepishly saying to selling out Madison
Square Garden coat
[Music]
she barely glanced up at me and kept
writing the number and I just said I'd
forget it forget it I just walked down
was like a [ __ ] I got to go all the
way down to the cellar I'm old I need my
nap so I'm riding down to the cellar and
I was [ __ ] pissed not because of that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was funny but what I was
pissed about was I was tired and I just
wanted to get on stage and now I got to
drag my old ass all the way down all the
way downtown where they know me right so
like half [ __ ] right so I get in the cab
so I call up Keith Robinson and I said
Keith I'm gonna give you a lot of
information here okay cuz I know it's
gonna get out at some point anyway so I
want to get this thrashing over worth
and the fact that I'm coming to you with
the information I want this thrashing to
be quick it's gonna be can be as mean as
it is but just give me two in the back
of the year so I left the whole message
on his cell phone and he was dying
laughing and he actually called the club
up and he thanked them but not knowing
who I was and said to my old ass-fucking
walking back out of the club so there
you go I'm in New York and I got a hero
sighs [ __ ] saying what's your
humility so anyway they go that's my New
York story and I have no and by the way
I got no beef against the the lol comedy
club I will [ __ ] do was set there
wouldn't have oh they'll have me
whatever it was a funny [ __ ] moment
although I was I was grumpy about it I'm
not gonna lie to you I didn't say
anything to the person but when I left
it's like goddamn not good [ __ ]
now I gotta [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] camp
you know people look at it by the way I
have not been doing good with the anger
because I haven't been seen the [ __ ]
therapist for a minute you know cuz I'm
out here so I need to get back to that
you know and my wife cycle why don't you
do therapy over the phone I'm like I
don't know cuz they record everything
because of the [ __ ] Snowden told us and
then somehow he got turned into a
villain and everybody went back to
[ __ ] buying flat-screen TVs and
getting [ __ ] Siri and bug in their
own [ __ ] house sorry anyways that's
the podcast a Thursday afternoon podcast
believe it or not I'm gonna actually be
watching the NBA Draft tonight it's not
something I want to do but I'm getting
together with some friends to smoke a
stick and they want to watch some Knick
fans diehard Knick fan so you know what
I'm talking about
burnsy right oh by the way when I wash
my clothes I found a $5 bill in floating
and you know not floating but all
soaking wet in the in the washing
machine so I was like ATS all [ __ ]
went and I was just like well just throw
it in the dryer you know who the [ __ ]
gonna look in there nobody gives a [ __ ]
so I threw the $5 in there came out was
all nice and dry Freddie to be spent I
felt like a [ __ ] count of feta all
right have a great weekend you [ __ ] and
I'll I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's over it's the
Monday morning podcast of Monday June
20th 2011 how the hell are you it's
quarter to eight in the morning my time
I got a bang this [ __ ] thing out here
in an hour cuz I got some people coming
over gonna be doing some work on my [ __ ]
and up yeah back in the day well my dog
was a [ __ ] a crazy dog we used to go
we would leave to go do some things and
then we come back and it tried to eat
its way through the molding and the door
and all this type of [ __ ] and my girl is
always like we have company and I was
like well I'm not getting it fixed until
the dog is not out of its goddamn mind
so that was a that was a long process
dog is not out of its mind it's not out
of its mind was nervous was scared he
say hey man where you guys go and I want
to go to me and me I got a bad feeling
about this man like that dude and
platoon right he would my dog she excuse
me she would freak out um but now we got
we have her crate trained so we stick
her in the crate she sits in there it's
her own little world she feels safe and
you know we put the music on she doesn't
know if we're home she doesn't know if
we're not home worked like a charm
that's basically what we did we would
put her in the in the crate and we turn
the crate around where the door is you
know and you just have it pointed at the
wall that prevented her from trying to
get out and then we had one of those
little baby cameras you know if you have
a baby and you're worried that it's
gonna you know start stealing things out
of your sock drawer if they give you
those little [ __ ] cameras to watch we
just used one of those and any time she
tried to break out of the crate we would
come in and go hey
all right and then what we finally end
up do is we just that whole process we
just put music on so she doesn't hear us
leave she doesn't know for home or not
every time she would start to get antsy
we would always poke our heads in going
hey knock it off and then she just kind
of fills that we're just in a different
room but now she just lays there she's
fine we can leave for hours so yes so
now I'm finally getting the [ __ ] work
done so I can have an apartment that
doesn't look like I had a [ __ ] hurt
or rats come through here so anyways
yeah they're coming here at like 9:00 so
I gotta bang this thing out here in an
hour
oh do I have some [ __ ] to talk about
this week first of all you know where
I'm supposed to be today people I'm
supposed to be a jury duty okay and for
the first time since I was out here I
was actually gonna show up you know I'm
in town here for the rest of June the
only thing else I have coming up as I'm
doing the greg Giraldo benefit on June
29th at The Wiltern Theatre with me and
about probably another 15 other
comedians Jeff Ross Christ when am I
gonna have that goddamn list I'll have a
next week right before the gig it's it's
gonna be it's gonna be a great night
obviously we all loved Greg and we want
his family to be taken care of so all
the money goes towards his wife and his
kids so great benefit so anyway so I'm
in town for the rest of the [ __ ]
month here and I'm supposed to do jury
duty and I thought it was like the old
school all right I got to go this day so
I'll go [ __ ] go down there and
evidently you're supposed to call within
five days of getting the you have jury
duty summons so I didn't call in time
you know so I called up and of course I
can't get a person hello you have called
the Los Angeles Department of jury duty
if you're a [ __ ] douche press what I
had to go through all of that crap just
to find out that I can't even go down
there and then they told me to pick
another date within six months so I say
I figured I'd pick you know around
Christmas so I picked [ __ ]
in December 22nd and they said we are
sorry that is more than six months away
and I said well then go [ __ ] yourself
and I hung up all right I tried I was
you know already I was to cook [ __ ]
go do jury duty I was gonna go down
there and one of those [ __ ] goddamn
what do you call it one of those dress
shirts you don't shirt you wear with a
suit and tie
you know once they have the short sleeve
I was gonna go down there with one of
those and a tie on some black frame
glasses I want to look like Michael
Douglas and falling down just to see
what trial I was going to get picked for
I was up for it 12 Angry Men I'm angry
I'm ready to [ __ ] go down there how
the [ __ ] you think he's [ __ ] not
guilty and going through that [ __ ] I was
up for it but evidently they have to
know you showing up you have to call and
confirm and I didn't so once again once
again I have to worry if I get pulled
over that that's going to show up but
fortunately I live in Los Angeles and
one of the great things about Los
Angeles is there's so much goddamn
traffic out here you can't speed I don't
drink and drive anymore
so uh I don't know I just don't see
myself getting pulled over plus I'm a
[ __ ] white guy who looks looks like
he's the guy who makes the chili at the
firehouse so I got that going for me you
know my I'm gonna jinx myself right now
I don't think I'm ever gonna get pulled
over out here so if they can't do that
then technically I don't really have to
go to jury duty you know and everybody
has their little [ __ ] ideas dude just
go down man when you go down there dude
you just say something [ __ ] racist
racist people always say that just say
go down there [ __ ] go the only thing
I don't like more than blacks it's the
[ __ ] Puerto Ricans you don't even get
me started on the [ __ ] Jews dude you
know don't they know that you're just
saying that at this point I mean unless
you're down there and you're really
dressed like Archie Bunker you know I
think if you were a racist
if you truly were a racist I don't think
you would say anything I think you would
go down there and you would act like you
weren't racist and then you would be
praying that you would get a defendant
of a race that you didn't like isn't
that what you would do instead of going
down there that's like selling drugs
would you go down there go and I sell
drugs you know I think racists know at
this point that they probably got to
keep their ideas to themselves unless
set up one of those Klan meetings you
know a bunch of douche bags sitting
around with a [ __ ] comforter thrown
over your face just [ __ ] getting all
sweaty under there your face breaking
out you know what's wrong with those
people anyways last week I talked I
discussed jerking off at work and
evidently my web guy said bill in
response to the jerking off at work
email I counted 26 emails of people
saying they have they have or currently
do jacket at work none of the stories
were good just painting gross pictures
this is why this is why I love the fact
that someone else reads these [ __ ]
emails before they sent him to me
because I didn't have to read all of
those he said but uh but I figure you
can do something with that stat most
said they find bathrooms or do it while
parked in their car if they're in the
field and then he goes here's an article
about Jimi Hendrix jerking it in the
army on The Smoking Gun calm by though I
[ __ ] hate The Smoking Gun com you
know just ratting everybody out I read
this whole thing it's like Jimi was it
[ __ ] he was in the army he had to go
clean up some [ __ ] some barracks and
he went in the bathroom he's rubbing one
about whatever went out he's in a stall
he's got the door [ __ ] closed so this
other douche goes yeah we was supposed
to clean up whatever and now he was gone
for about 20 minutes I then went into
the latrine and saw Hendrix sitting in
the last commode I guess cuz he could
see his feet how did he know was Jimi
did he have his army boots like purple
with some glitter on him
already drop an acid he said I thought
he was sitting there sleeping so I stood
on a stool in the commode next to his
and looked into his commode why didn't
you [ __ ] just knock on the door there
Don't Ask Don't Tell huh who the [ __ ] is
this guy
he goes there sad Hendrix masturbating
himself this is in 1962 evidently this
was still considered some sort of weird
behavior at that time Straubel I guess
that's his buddy Straubel there's a name
that just really got [ __ ] out of
commission huh not enough men with the
last name Straubel they were all broads
and they all got banged and they got
different names at that time Straubel
came into the latrine and I motioned to
him to come over and witness what was
happening is that what you two little
fruits did come here let's Jimmy's
touching himself why wouldn't you have
the normal reaction either knock on the
door or if you peeked over thinking you
were gonna make fun of him for evidently
taking an odourless [ __ ] you know you
would have peeked over in the second you
saw him jerking off why wouldn't you
would have been like oh my god what dude
I'm sorry I'm sorry and just slowly
backed out and then just you know spoke
in tongues like those [ __ ] Jesus
freaks trying to get that image out of
your head now what does this guy do
he calls in old Strobel haste Roby come
here you want to watch another man
[ __ ] jerk his goddamn dick you know
what Kowalski I don't think I want to
why don't you go [ __ ]
why don't you go sit another one of the
latrines and [ __ ] think about what
you just saw
goddamn weirdo so anyways he goes so
evidently Straubel goes in there too
he took a look and then went back into
the squad bay and started working again
really that was it you guys didn't
snicker you didn't laugh you went in
there yes I confirm private Kowalski
that uh private Hendricks is in fact
jerking his dick then what you did you
went in you told on him so you get
another shiny thing in the front of your
shirt you [ __ ] rat that's what they
should call The Smoking Gun they should
call it the rat comm hey isn't that
ironic that I finally read something
from The Smoking Gun when I I'm actually
supposed to have jury duty isn't that
interesting there was a lot of [ __ ] this
week that [ __ ] annoyed me on the gas
mileage thing I brought up last week how
I was watching the goodbye girl and she
was standing at the corner characters
were standing in front of a [ __ ]
Subaru and it got thirty nine miles per
gallon and here it is thirty six years
later and my car only gets [ __ ] a
hybrid only gets 41 miles per gallon so
this brilliant guy writes in and he goes
and he starts talking about leaded gas
and all this [ __ ] how cars today are
heavier this [ __ ] [ __ ] thought cars
today were heavier than cars back in the
day you know like the 1959 Cadillac I'm
sure that that car was lighter than your
average Toyota Camry so anyways this
somebody sent me let me know I actually
read this guy's this guy's response here
one of the many that I got on the gas
mileage thing it always blows my mind
what people [ __ ] respond to so this
guy ends up writing me he goes there are
two reasons wait a minute it's loading
loading no he gave me all these [ __ ]
reasons and I basically responded with
so basic you're telling me he basically
said that it had
nothing to do with money it had to do
with the weight of the cars and somehow
the the mixture of the gasoline that we
use nowadays that's why they just can't
figure out a [ __ ] way to get more
than like better than what's the highest
you've seen like 4045 this guy tried to
say well actually there are things that
get a hundred miles to gallon their
scooters I would a [ __ ] because there's
two reason why old cars have such highly
high published gas mileage for one the
EPA test simply used to provide higher
numbers sir they've been doing that
right up until the last couple of years
ago in fact the year before I bought my
Prius they were legally able to claim
that it got like 50 v I actually almost
60 miles per gallon before they crack
down on the hybrid and made him say
actually forty ones I'm aware of the EPA
tests I'm aware that they do it when
there's no headwind I'm aware that most
of the test is when they're [ __ ]
going 25 miles an hour and they only
drive the car 55 miles an hour for about
[ __ ] 30 seconds I realize that the
numbers are skewed okay he said it's
been revived several times over the
decades yeah so my Prius your Prius
would get like seventy miles per gallon
on the old test no it wouldn't sir no it
wouldn't it would get more like 60
that's what it did look let's just say
that it would get 70 who gives a [ __ ] he
goes where where am I the second reason
is safety features check out the weight
of your vehicles cars have gotten
heavier know they have it my Prius is
not heavier than a [ __ ] Subaru in the
1970s it isn't dude I'm old enough to
remember when cars actually had metal on
their dashboard they're all plastic
hunks of [ __ ] now he goes cars if even
15 years ago featured death traps when
compared to the modern cars no they
didn't they've had the crumple free
zones those doesn't look crumple free
they've had those crumple zones for
years sir in nineteen [ __ ] 88 I was
coming home from a Christmas party drunk
off
my ass sitting in the [ __ ] passenger
seat of a Pontiac Grand Prix we pulled
up to a red light there was a [ __ ]
Jeep cj7 the old-school ones sitting
there all right
we saw it I saw it the driver saw it but
the alcohol didn't quite see it and we
just thought I went least we're slowing
down
but we didn't come to his complete stop
and just completely rear-ended this guy
all right there wasn't a scratch on the
[ __ ] Jeep this goddamn car folded up
like a [ __ ] accordion the engine
dropped down underneath us and I got I
didn't even get a boo-boo I just sort of
you know I mean I didn't have a seat
belt on or nothing the car was designed
to take 80% of the [ __ ] impact all
right you're sitting in your cubicle
just tossing these [ __ ] numbers out
all right so basically my response is
I'm saying it has nothing to do with
money in the oil companies so basically
you're telling me is that nowadays I can
have a video conference with somebody in
Brazil while my entire music collection
is in my pocket on a phone that is also
a camera and a video recorder I can
upload the content onto the internet and
potentially have it viewed by every
person in the [ __ ] world
but we can't make a car that does any
better than 40 miles per gallon so
fortunately you know everything else has
[ __ ] progressed except for gas
mileage dude I'm telling you they have
the technology to get like 500 miles per
gallon they're just not gonna [ __ ]
put it out because that's how powerful
the goddamn oil companies are they're
right up there with the banks you got
the banks and then you got the oil
company the banks control the money
supply and then the oil companies they
control energy okay you control energy
you can you control the [ __ ]
population do you know that they're
actually out here there's people there
selling kits out here to have your own
[ __ ] windmill so you can get yourself
off the grid so then they immediately
pass the [ __ ] law
General Electric that General Electric
had to come around and make sure that
everything was safe they had to get
their [ __ ] noses back in there so
because they can't have people disappear
off the [ __ ] grid you can't have
people getting free energy other than
the cost of the [ __ ] windmill you
can't have him sitting there and every
time the goddamn wind blows it recharges
a generator and now I don't have to work
as much if I don't have to work as much
I don't have to go into debt you're
getting yourself off of the [ __ ]
treadmill and they can't have that all
right god dammit I wish I was more
intelligent so I could explain this
better but you know what there's a great
documentary I'm actually gonna email
this guy back it's called the gas hole
full documentary and there's they and
they have everything from they have
everything from the the urban myth of
the water powered carburetor which this
guy who I brought to me completely
dismissed
he completely dismissed any sort of that
that that exists because he sits in a
cubicle and I sit in a [ __ ] bedroom
alright and he tries to just say that's
just another media hoax oh you know they
said do we beat Eisenhower or [ __ ]
like dumb [ __ ] like that
ok this so this document here everything
from like the urban myth that that these
water powered cars existed all the way
up to actual a retired scientist who
worked for shell who you just have to
watch this documentary they was showing
there was a book out that claimed that
they could get 149 miles per gallon in
the 1950s on like a Packard or a DeSoto
and by the 70s this scientist who worked
for shell said they had gotten it up to
a thousand miles per gallon alright I
don't know why people think that it's
it's absolutely impossible to improve
the gas mileage some people feel that I
don't know why people feel like we can't
come up with anything better than the
gas combustion engine it's complete
[ __ ] but it's the same level of
[ __ ] as that there's an actual
difference between a Democrat and a
Republican watch this documentary the
gas hole we're going to have
the link up on the Monday morning
podcast just watch this [ __ ] and I don't
know what to tell you some of it looks
like okay did they have this old guy
going you know on this guy showed up
when he heard it was a contraption made
Auto you know it was powered on water
and then he claimed that shell bought
the patent gave him a million dollars
and then he could never [ __ ] you know
make another one now that's the kind of
[ __ ] some old guys saying that he saw it
on a salt flat in the 1950s I'm not
going with that all right I'm not that
much of a [ __ ] whack job but when a
guy who work used to work for shell is
coming out saying that type of stuff
it's just it gets to the point like are
all of these people nuts you know what I
mean there's no [ __ ] way I don't give
a [ __ ] whether there's lead and gas
whether there's not lead and gas how
much the car [ __ ] weighs or any of
that [ __ ] there's no [ __ ] way
that in in almost 40 years you can't do
better than two more miles per gallon I
absolutely [ __ ] refuse to believe it
III raps I [ __ ] refuse to believe it
I think it's complete [ __ ] horseshit
it's just another way to keep control of
the herd now if you want to argue that
you need to keep control to herd or
there's gonna be absolute chaos so we
have to keep cars down like that I will
listen to that argument but if you're
gonna come at me and tell me that in two
thousand [ __ ] eleven okay when I'm
reading [ __ ] that in the medical field
they can now grow a [ __ ] a new colon
for somebody outside of the body I read
this this thing on that Ted calm this
woman had a completely ulcerated large
intestine so they took some sort of
tissue carved culture whatever the [ __ ]
that means out of her of diseased colon
use that to then grow another one
outside of her body when they were done
growing it they took the old one out and
put the new one in like she went down to
Midas muffler and it totally [ __ ]
worked okay up until like five years ago
you were looking at a colostomy bag you
would have a bag of [ __ ] right under her
[ __ ] right titty for the rest of her
goddamn life her social life would have
been Oh
for okay if they can do that you're
telling me you're still gonna tell me
they can't do anything about it in about
40 [ __ ] 45 miles a gallon
you're really gonna sit there and
believe that in your goddamn cubicle
that they just can't [ __ ] dis can't
[ __ ] figure it out the only way I can
get like a hundred miles a gallon is if
I ride on a [ __ ] scooter you sir
believe in Santa Claus I just it just
blows my [ __ ] mind
how some people just sit there and they
believe that they believe that they're
not even conscious of the amount of
times that they themselves lie during
the course of the day that they
themselves spin [ __ ] to try to try to
advance their own [ __ ] lives why
would you think that a goddamn
corporation would be honest you know
this guy's saying advances in your
computing your music collection and
video conferences are strictly due to
more law Moore's law scuse me computing
power roughly doubles per square inch
every 18 months that means since 1978
it's doubled 28 times yes I understand I
understand that computers have advanced
why hasn't gas milage it's just it's
just [ __ ] I and this is nothing - so
then he uses that same sort of ratio
with the gas mileage and then he goes
back to what the [ __ ] the gas mileage is
in the 70 was is if that wasn't a
[ __ ] lie I don't I give up sir could
you please watch this gas hole
documentary could you please watch it I
know you're not a [ __ ] it just
frustrates me when people believe in
corporations that they're actually doing
the right thing despite the fact the
amount of times that there's been
unclassified information and then you
find out kind of what's really going on
and every time it's you know it's
usually some diabolical [ __ ] how many
call
races have to dump [ __ ] into the water
supply before you stop trusting them you
know the goddamn [ __ ] place where
they make the iPhone there's people
jumping to their deaths rather than
because that's a better option than
sitting there making another [ __ ]
iPhone and then people actually believe
the horseshit that corporations say well
well less you want that iPhone to cost
nine million dollars that's the only way
to build one
really or maybe you yourself shouldn't
make 80 million dollars a [ __ ] year
or whatever you're making the reason why
if you actually paid that guy a decent
wage or that poor woman a decent [ __ ]
wage the reason why then it's gonna cost
me way money more money for the [ __ ]
eye
iPhone is because you're not going to
take a pay cut and the reason why you
make the amount of [ __ ] money that
you make is because you're exploiting
poor people who live in third-world
countries that's why you make 80 million
dollars a year not because you're
[ __ ] worth it your greedy [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh I'm on my high horse this
[ __ ] week all right
let's [ __ ] try and lighten it up
everybody you wouldn't know it but yet
another Boston team won a [ __ ]
championship this week congratulations
to the 2011 Stanley Cup champions the
Boston Bruins
I gotta admit as a sports fan I didn't
know that I was ever gonna see it I've
been watching the Bruins since 1982 and
going through all those Harry Sinden
years where Harry Sinden was a great guy
he might even be in the Hockey Hall of
Fame for all I know he's been around so
[ __ ] long he just hated free agency he
[ __ ] resented it and I we just never
seem to be making the moves you know or
even when we had the team they just
somehow we just I don't there was two
all the years we could never get by the
Canadians and then when we finally get
by the goddamn Canadians we have we ran
into those great Edmonton teams and I
don't know
I'm not gonna be one of those guys who
was like dude I called it I knew there
was something special I didn't think we
had enough I didn't think I thought
because we didn't have a Crosby and a
Vette chicken we didn't have like that
super super star offensive player I
still felt we needed that despite the
fact that we had Tim Thomas and you know
Lucic crazy all these guys patrice
bergeron I knew we had a great team but
I thought we were good enough to get to
the Eastern Conference Finals that's
what I thought and I thought when we
went up against tamp I said I believe I
said on the podcast I thought not only
not only was Tampa gonna beat us I
thought that they were going to I
thought that they were gonna win the
whole the whole thing because I thought
they had it I thought they had it when
they had Stamkos Saint Louie
Luca VA they had a great goaltender to
just look like they just had that
momentum thing that I had seen every
[ __ ] year the Bruins would go to the
playoffs we've run into a team like that
and I have to admit I am absolutely
[ __ ] stunned I can't believe we want
it and I screamed like a little girl
when we when I when I figured out that
there wasn't enough time left for
Vancouver to check to catch up and it
was right before Brad Marchand scored
the the empty net goal we were up three
to nothing and I believe there was about
five minutes left and it just seemed
like Vancouver couldn't get it past
center ice at that point and I screamed
like a little girl I was like oh my god
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
oh my god I was freaking the [ __ ] out I
was worried I was in the Chicago theater
I just done one of those antisocial
Network tourist shows with Jim Breuer
Dave Attell and the mastermind behind
the tour Jimmy Norton and it worked I
was so [ __ ] freaking out that I was
gonna miss Game seven I'm like what are
the [ __ ] odds you know that I would
have a Wednesday gig a Wednesday I never
work on Wednesday I might travel on a
[ __ ] Wednesday but I'd have a gig
well it worked out where I ended up with
the way it timed out I got brought
onstage with about two minutes left in
the first period no wait I actually went
up on during the intermission between
the first and the second period and by
the time I got offstage and oh by the
way I was so into the Bruins games I I
didn't even take a look at the theater
which is something I usually do before I
go went out on stage just to kind of get
a feel for the room and that was pretty
pretty breathtaking I don't know if you
guys have ever been to the Chicago
theater but it looked like half of Royal
Albert Hall it really looked like
whoever designed that definitely took
some nods from that place it was
absolutely one of the most beautiful
theaters I've ever been in here in the
States Royal Albert Hall well I think
will always be the greatest one I ever
went to that's in London for anybody who
didn't listen to my podcast when I went
over there but anyways just absolutely
gorgeous theater went out there went out
it had just a great set did my time and
ran offstage you don't know when I came
up I think there were about six minutes
into the third period which was actually
a great thing because when I watched the
replay Vancouver had the puck in our
zone feel like it felt like the first
ten minutes of the period so I avoided
aging another 10 years and I think it
was one nothing at that point then -
nothing than three nothing and you know
Boston fan I I was beaten down for so
[ __ ] long I still always wait for the
other shoe to drop despite the
unbelievable amount of success of our
teams in the last nine years and I was
just thinking okay they got to come out
on fresh ice in the third period please
don't let him get a quick goal and like
I said once it ticked down there was
like 10 minutes left I started getting
that feeling and but it wasn't until
five minutes left that I finally gave
into it and and there was this other
Boston fan going when they were up like
two three nothing or two nothing he was
like dude it's over it's over he was one
of those guys I'm like dude I still let
some of that old lady in me but um
I can't I can't [ __ ] believe it
absolutely cannot believe it and
watching them go watching chars skate
over looking back at the rest of his
teammates before he picked up the the
Stanley Cup was one of the greatest
things I ever saw and it was just
[ __ ] awesome it was [ __ ] awesome
it's the best trophy in sports
I got a mitt I think I actually enjoyed
this one better than the Red Sox beating
the Yankees in 2004 if he can [ __ ]
believe that how satisfying that was
they were just like because it's just a
great sport and I also like that there
wasn't anything that cartoonish you know
curse of the babe horseshit and now they
don't have to go talk to [ __ ] lobster
fishermen tying sailor knots like you
know I just I don't know it was [ __ ]
awesome my condolences to the Vancouver
Canucks fans I know what it's like to
lose a game seven in the in the playoffs
but not in the finals that must have
been absolutely devastating and I
actually had a hookup for tickets if you
can believe it and I was really bummed
like [ __ ] I could have gone but I got to
admit man after watching that rioting
afterwards I was actually psyched I
didn't go that was absolute insanity and
I know people in Vancouver I know what
you're gonna say like listen don't
define us by a hundred thousand bad
apples what the [ __ ] is going on in
Canada all right I'm down here in the
States and according to Michael Moore
and his goddamn documentaries Canada is
this [ __ ] utopia they have night
nationwide health care you can leave
your doors unlocked you know you can
[ __ ] go up and pet a moose right on
its nose everybody so goddamn friendly
up there I was talking about this last
year when I did the Montreal Comedy
Festival you know the if it's so [ __ ]
friendly why do you guys riot like
full-on [ __ ] riot it's not like you
lit a [ __ ] trashcan on fire or you
jumped up and down on a couple of cars
you started attacking stores I mean you
took it to a whole nother [ __ ] level
you know I don't know what why does
America the only one that has that
reputation I actually watched you know
Vancouver the last time they had a riot
was when they lost to the Rangers or a
riot to this magnitude of course I
didn't do enough research was in 1994
after they lost to the [ __ ] in New York
Rangers you know and I think there's a
great there's a great YouTube clip of it
with where the lady the lady on the news
goes she was talking about how shocking
this footage was before we go to it it's
very shocking and blah blah blah and
this is the type of thing that you would
expect to see in America not in Canada
which is funny cuz we're all in America
we're in North America what she should
have said was the United States she was
basically it's the type of thing you'd
expect to see in the United States and I
got pissed for half a second and I was
like well you know she is right I mean
it was right after the [ __ ] LA riots
and but this is the thing Vancouver had
a riot in 1994 so I looked up you know
riots because I knew Montreal had some
riots Montreal rioted in 2010 and 2008
both both times they rioted was after
they won games they won games and they
started to burn down their city and like
I said it's not like it's like 40
[ __ ] people you know going around you
know tipping over trash cans and doing
some sort of misdemeanor rioting this is
full-on tipping cars over I mean it was
[ __ ] birthday and then in Toronto
they had a riot in 2010 at the the g20
riots now that one has a little more
understandable g20 evidently is twenty
banks from around the [ __ ] world
that are trying to get together to solve
the the economic crisis they're trying
to solve it now I'm sure that guy
believes that oil companies are not
involved are not throwing any they're
not going on buying up patents by people
who are inventing more efficient engines
why would they do that just because they
have billions of dollars and it's
financially in their best interest to
keep gas mileage down as low as they
possibly can so they can all make more
money why would they do things like that
you never notice that every once in a
while inventions come out you're like
holy [ __ ] that's gonna [ __ ] over that
industry and then they kind of disappear
do you remember that [ __ ] on TV just for
1995 like disposable razors one of the
most one of the biggest [ __ ] scams on
the planet not only the fact that
there's no way to sharpen the [ __ ]
thing they it's also the fact that they
charge you like [ __ ] $900 to buy
eight of them like they're made out of
gold rather than some really cheap
[ __ ] metal it's a complete sorry I
got cut off they're the stupid batteries
ran out anyways yes so they yet rather
than they're made out of some cheap kind
of metal and then one year all of a
sudden I saw somebody came up when I was
1995 things what you know is a hunk of
[ __ ] but basically showed you could
sharpen your disposable razors and I'm
like that's [ __ ] great and then all
of a sudden it's gone and no one comes
out and makes a better one guys who
shave and who are sick of making of
paying 9 zillion dollars for [ __ ]
disposable razors if they made a quality
one for 30 bucks wouldn't you go out and
go buy it I mean is it that [ __ ] hard
to come up with that [ __ ] invention
why hasn't anybody come up with that the
only inventions that they seem to be
coming up with that comes from just
regular people that they can actually
get out there it's just dumb [ __ ] like
stuff like oh you're sick of dropping
your keys between your [ __ ] ass and
the console here's a piece of foam will
stick in there but anything else that is
gonna [ __ ] over another like really
powerful corporation never seems to come
out and I'm telling you I know I'm a
paranoid psychopath but
alright I'll admit that ok I will
definitely admit that but on the other
side you're really gonna sit there and
think that these corporations don't have
so much [ __ ] money that they don't go
out there and try to crush the [ __ ]
competition and that if somebody goes
out there and invent something that
would drastically compromise their
bottom line they don't go out there and
try to throw a bunch of [ __ ] money at
the person to buy their patent no you
don't think that here comes Santa Claus
here comes Santa Claus right down Santa
Claus Lane yeah I'm telling you you got
you [ __ ] head up your ass and it must
be a [ __ ] absolute utopia an absolute
[ __ ] utopia that you live in that you
actually sit there and believe believe
in these all of this [ __ ] all the weight
cigarette companies covering up all
kinds of studies and that type of [ __ ]
all the things that they did the stuff
that they put in them to deliberately
make it even more addicting to ramp
tobacco was already addicting then they
threw other stuff in there and they
actually ramped it up so high that it
was more addicting than [ __ ] heroin
you're telling me but the oil companies
the oil companies all those guys those
guys are [ __ ] those are quality human
beings right there those people who work
in the the oil oil industry their salts
of the earth kinds of people right there
they don't give a [ __ ]
we're over in the Middle East right now
people because we so care about our
fellow human beings that we want to go
over there and liberate them that's
that's what we want to do now I'm not
saying you as an individual sitting
there and you compete cubicle does not
have compassion or empathy for people
around the [ __ ] globe but I'm just
saying when you get up to the low the
the tippity-top up there it's it's it's
all about money and it's about power and
it's about controlling people that's all
it's about it has nothing to do with
them helping liberate and just complete
horseshit it's like a catcher who
catches a ball that's a little outside
he tries to frame it and make it look
like a strike that's just the
[ __ ] that they say to you i 100% [ __ ]
believe that okay they don't even give a
[ __ ] about people in this country the
way they handled [ __ ] New Orleans the
way insurance companies are just able to
walk away after these people people paid
money to have insurance for that exact
[ __ ] disaster
I've worked down in New Orleans the
stories people have that insurance
companies come in like yeah listen we're
not covering anything above four feet
cuz the water lines only at four feet so
uh take it or leave it
go [ __ ] yourself all of that insurance
companies oil companies it's politics
it's all complete [ __ ] and I am
absolutely I'm not mad at you if you
believe in those industries I I'm more
fascinated by you so whatever you would
think that I wouldn't have this sort of
[ __ ] fire and brimstone this week
would you with another Boston team
winning a championship I actually have
to admit as a sports fan I I said I know
I've said it countless times in this
podcast that if the Bruins won the
Stanley Cup that was the only other
championship I needed to see by a Boston
team I was going to retire as a sports
fan which is what I think I'm gonna do
I'm done it's not gonna get any better
than this I think I'm walking away
walking I'm gonna retired like jay-z did
after the black album and I'm just gonna
drop in and do some guest spots every
once in a while I'm trying to figure out
what teams I'm back into the Pittsburgh
Pirates I've been following them lately
still the 1979 team that was my favorite
world series of all time other than
obviously watching the Red Sox win it in
2004 I [ __ ] loved that team I love
the players I love their uniforms and I
loved Sister Sledge it was just it was a
[ __ ] try not trifecta that was four
there I suck at math whatever so I
actually went back and I started looking
this is what a [ __ ] nerd I am I'm
looking at Championships and I'm sitting
here trying to think and within a
ten-year period basically continue
period from February from February 2002
to June of 2011 less than 10 years
Boston a a city with four teams one team
in every major sport won at least one
championship in all four sports we ran
the table all right
the [ __ ] championship Grand Slam
and I'm saying we yes I am because I
live vicariously through them all right
and don't even give me that [ __ ] dude
you didn't do anything
[ __ ] you I get devastated when they lose
so why I'm not allowed to have some joy
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I know this is ridiculous let me have my
bread and circus
so anyways we've run the [ __ ] table
so I actually looked back all the way
until the 19 [ __ ] 20s to try to find
another you can't even do it I was
trying to find another city that has
four teams that is won all four trophies
within ten years and no one's ever done
it and you can only go back to 1950
because that's when the NBA started okay
their Lakers with your [ __ ] BA a
championship in 1949 that you add to try
to come close to the Celtics you [ __ ]
sorry the closest I saw was in the 1960s
and it was the city of New York and they
have six teams so they don't really
qualify and even then the Rangers [ __ ]
it up for them the Yankees won and let's
see 61 60 they won in 60 60 62 the Mets
won is 69 the 68 Jets team won and then
the 1970 Knicks won so that was four but
they didn't get the Stanley Cup and not
to mention they would double down in
both [ __ ] football and baseball so it
doesn't really count but I wasn't able
to find another one
the closest [ __ ] that I was able to find
was Pittsburgh the Pirates Steelers won
it in 79 and then the Penguins in it but
they only have three teams but the
Penguins wanted in 91 that
was like the closest I was able to find
I'm sure there's there's some other
things here and I bet New Yorkers were
trying to get technical and be like well
the Islanders are in New York they want
it go [ __ ] yourselves
go [ __ ] yourselves um and actually in
New York City is actually very quietly a
devastating place to be a sports fan
it's just that the Yankees are so
successful and they so blow themselves
every 20 minutes about their amazing
accomplishments that you never really
think about Jets fans Mets fans Knicks
fans Rangers fans Giants though Giants
are a quality squad they've won three
and as far as being a football like
three to me is the tipping point where
you are then into the upper echelon of
teams although with Green Bay now with
four I don't know because you got they
got four Cowboys and 49ers have five and
the Steelers have six so I now think
that because the Packers won that having
three is now a little more mediocre
which also nope knocks my Patriots down
but anyways we won seven [ __ ]
championships
we ran the goddamn table we got all the
[ __ ] trophies and I'm done so now
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying now
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna
sponsor you know like when you sponsor a
starving child I'm gonna sponsor a City
I'm gonna start rooting for him all
right
I'll root for the San Diego Padres but I
will not root for the San Diego Chargers
just because I went down there to a
sporting event and it was one of the
worst times I ever went one of the worst
[ __ ] fans just like I swear to god
dude it's just I can't explain it you'd
have to come out here it's not fun on
the west coast
it just isn't they have [ __ ] fans slash
then they also have like the [ __ ] the
the gang culture out here and it's just
it's just not a good time like I have no
desire like I like the Dodgers I'd like
to go to a game but I just really don't
have any desire to go out there and
either sit down low with Hollywood fans
who show up late or sit in the upper
deck
with fans who they can't go they can't
talk sports beyond Boston footage sucks
and then you sprinkle in there the gang
culture slash tattoo on your [ __ ]
neck I'll stab you after the game
and it's I don't know it's not it's not
fun and I went to games in Philly in New
York and those fans are [ __ ] animals
Boston fans are [ __ ] animals Vick
[ __ ] Canada they like that goddamn
city's on fire granted I haven't been
there during that time I just you know I
don't know I just have not had a good
time here like someone was trying to
tell me that LA is actually gonna get a
football team he's like do too you
psyched are you psyched that's like that
I'm not going to that [ __ ] I'm not gonna
go to it unless they give it like a
really like I don't know like they got
you know what if I if I was like the
mayor of this city I would demand that
they give the team some neutral colors
usually you want to have a badass
uniform give it some neutral colors so
the gangs won't wear the colors you know
and start going down there like they
used to go down they were like the
Raiders like the Raiders were probably
the worst franchise that you could have
brought down here to LA you know with
the the awful relationship between the
police and in the poorer neighborhoods
like that was one thing that actually
fascinated me like I wanted to ask why
why Vancouver alright I'm not gonna sit
here and judge you guys because we had
the LA riots all right we have a very
questionable foreign policy at this
point so who the [ __ ] am I to look down
my nose at you all right despite the
fact you [ __ ] have been doing it and
doing it to us forever alright I'm gonna
give you a chance to explain those riots
rather than me sitting here way down and
[ __ ] Los Angeles like I know what's
going on why do you why do you think why
do you guys riot when you lose the
Stanley Cup because I know it isn't just
about that that that means there's
there's another area of frustration in
your life and that's why people go to
sports it's a [ __ ] outlet
it's an outlet you're divorced you're
playing you're paying child support your
wife was a [ __ ] about you trying to have
the kids this Father's Day weekend you
know maybe at least the home team can
win a championship and then it doesn't
happen and then you want to smash the
[ __ ] Starbucks sign what's going on
up there why does that what why do you
guys do that [ __ ] because that wasn't
just drunk fans who were upset like that
was [ __ ] epic that was like hours and
hours like you know the footage that's
like three blocks away because the
reporters are scared to get close to it
and there's smoke and fire uh why do you
guys riot cuz according to Michael Moore
down here you guys live in a [ __ ]
utopia you know I don't [ __ ] know so
anyways let's get on with the [ __ ]
podcast here these painters and
woodworking people are gonna be here
soon do you there's how much of a
[ __ ] nerd I am do you guys know that
I can off the top of my head name every
champion in all four sports from 1960 on
and now after compiling this list I can
now kind of do it I can do it in hockey
and I kind of do it in baseball from
1950 on I don't know there's something
wrong with me that I'm absolutely
fascinated with this [ __ ] like that I'm
absolutely fascinated that like from
from 1940 to 1970 Montreal 112 Stanley
Cups in Toronto 110 how fascinating that
is to me that they were basically going
blow for blow like Lakers Celtics during
that time and then Toronto fell off and
Montreal put it out of reach when in
seven in the 70s I just find it
fascinating that from 1940 to 1970
Montreal wins 12 Toronto wins 10 the Red
Wings get 5 and it really put into
perspective the Rangers the Bruins and
blackhawks how we were [ __ ] we all
just one one how we were kind of the
doormats of the league and I don't know
thank God for [ __ ] Detroit doing
something for him the American teams but
also that was during the I actually look
at what Toronto did is is a more of an
amazing accomplishment because they
didn't have the advantage that Montreal
had with that first pick of all French
born Canadian players which to me to
this day if you're gonna put an asterisk
next to anything you that's [ __ ] a
ridiculous advantage a game that is
invented in Canada all right so you
already have that advantage half the
people in America didn't even know what
the [ __ ] the sport was and then you you
had you have a certain section of Canada
that is just your draft picks in your
draft picks alone until you're done
picking them and then everybody else can
get the scraps it's just [ __ ] beyond
me I don't know this is gonna [ __ ]
annoy people who aren't into sports
let's let's move on here with the with
the podcast cuz the the people are
coming here soon let me get back to
within the inbox here please watch that
documentary by the way the gas hole will
have the the the link the full
documentary it's absent I only watched
the first 15 minutes of it and if you're
any sort of thinking human being it was
everything that you're already kind of
new anyways here's another one bill in
the 70s they were driving leaded
gasoline remember the difference may
come from the lack of lead cars
performed better on leaded gas I
appreciate that it's true that we are
being manipulated by corporate America
so well then pick pick a side I
understand
actually I don't understand the
difference between leaded and unleaded
gasoline I don't understand the
difference of that okay I guess that
that performed better but unleaded was
better for the environment okay
scientifically I can't explain why that
is but I'm also not a [ __ ] and I
understand and I've read enough on
corporations I understand how they
[ __ ] work that's all about the bottom
and every quarter they have to show a
profit or it's considered a failure
they can't even show the same profit
that can t be like we made six billion
last quarter and we made six billion
this quarter that's considered a failure
they have to go up to seven billion now
at some point you're gonna exhaust all
ethical ways of making money and you're
gonna start delving into the world of
[ __ ] evil which is I think that
they're they're up to their heads in it
I don't buy it
anyways bill loved the podcast this is
such a great way to start the reason the
u.s. camry gets 26 miles per gallon and
the Pakistani version is gets 39 is
simple weight it's simple it's simple
controlling the world's energy is a
simple thing the US version has airbags
crumple zones roll cages a roll cage it
doesn't have a [ __ ] roll cage you
[ __ ] it might be structurally more
sound it doesn't have it really does
have a roll cage and the [ __ ] doors
are welded which adds 650 pounds to the
weight of the car imagine the mileage
you would get in your Prius with those
fat twins Abba Baba but you have you
you're an idiot you ever you're not an
idiot you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about I refuse to believe
that okay you just like me you're a
[ __ ] regular person you went up you
look for you looked at some stats to try
and support your [ __ ] argument just
like I'm doing but I'm sticking by this
one I know I'm [ __ ] right on this one
I remember one time I had this old
piece-of-shit truck right that I drove
for like 10 years because I knew I
wanted to be a comedian and I didn't
want to go into debt so when the engine
finally died I threw a new engine in
there and the guy told me he needed to
rebuild the carburetor I'm like you
don't need to rebuild the carburetor so
you know what this [ __ ] did he [ __ ]
adjusted the carburetor so I would just
get shitty gas mileage hoping I would be
an absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] and then drive
back and be like well I guess you're
right I'm just I'm just chowing through
gas here that's what this [ __ ]
did at his little garage
this little piece of [ __ ] did that
because it wasn't enough that he [ __ ]
made 1,600 [ __ ] bucks off me he wanted
to make like [ __ ] 1,900 bucks so he
did that just as a [ __ ] individual
and you're gonna try and tell me that a
corporation that basically controls the
world [ __ ] energy he's not gonna buy
up patents by people that that are that
are that are making or coming up with
carburetors and stuff like car berets
but by coming up with with with
alternate ways of powering a car more
efficiently they're not going to buy
that up do they have that host Stanley
Mayer thing and that's not a conspiracy
theory either we actually we actually
played the news clip on the Opie and
Anthony show
Stanley Mayer great news for individuals
but bad news for oil companies claims
he's come up with an engine that can run
on any type of water fresh water salt
water rain water doesn't make a
difference and he claims he can drive
across the country on 28 gallons of
water this is of such interest the
Pentagon is sending a lieutenant-colonel
out there that was the actual news clip
from the Opie and Anthony show it was an
actual news clip it's not some [ __ ]
I read on a [ __ ] website okay now
what happened after that nobody knows
but basically within 10 years
Stanley was dead and his car disappeared
and his brother right now is trying to
get the car back and nobody knows where
the [ __ ] it is all right
I surely believe that the quickest death
sentence you could possibly have is to
go in the news and claim that you've
come out with an alternate source of
energy that's going to put a corporation
out of business that is making that is
projected to make three hundred and
fifty billion dollars next year how much
do you think your life is worth and if
you have three hundred and fifty billion
dollars how easy is it do you think to
get somebody to solve this problem
you can't have people getting free
energy alright because I they're not
gonna work every time the [ __ ] wind
blows I can watch another [ __ ] eight
hours of TV you know am I gonna be
putting in for overtime my gonna be
working like a dog like these other
goddamn people you know if every time it
rains I got enough [ __ ] water to
[ __ ] drive all the way to goddamn
Kansas City I got enough water to drive
to Kansas City and back do you think
that they can have that I'm telling you
if when it rained if it rained oil let's
just flip this for a second if it rained
oil and it was a lubricant but somehow
it made the trees grow I guarantee you
whatever powered the cars would not be
oil gas and oil I guarantee you it
wouldn't it would be something else they
have to make it they have to keep you
away from it am i out of my [ __ ] I
probably am out of my mind I just don't
I don't believe it I just don't [ __ ]
I don't believe it I don't believe any
of it and I think anybody out there
who's tried to climb any sort of like
ladder of power you haven't noticed that
the higher up you went the more
compromised what the [ __ ] the more you
had to compromise what you wanted my
business is no different it's no [ __ ]
different the higher up you get the more
is at stake the more money is at stake
the more the art gets compromised look
at this [ __ ] I can say whatever the [ __ ]
I want on this goddamn podcast there's
nothing at stake I don't make any
[ __ ] money off of this [ __ ] all right
but if all of a sudden I started getting
advertising on this thing right making a
severe level of advertising to the point
let's say I was actually able to make a
million dollars a year off of this [ __ ]
and all of a sudden I'm going off on
Jesus and that type of [ __ ] and then all
of a sudden some [ __ ] advertisers it
goes hey we're gonna pull the spots here
and your money is gonna drop down back
down to nothing or whatever drop down to
like a hundred grand a year
you're telling me in my head I'm not
gonna start thinking like well maybe I
won't say what I think about religion
okay
that's just a million dollars forget
about 350 billion dollars in some douche
bag on Long Island comes up with a
[ __ ] car that can run on water you
know and he's not Whitman that guy
wasn't evident ly willing to sell his
[ __ ] invention I got to tell you this
people if you're out there and you're
working on an engine that can work on
somehow is powered by water don't go to
the news with it
all right I don't know how to get it out
there but I'm telling you if you are
able to come come up with something like
that and let's say on the sly you
started building them all right there's
no way to keep it a secret and when the
oil companies found out that you had it
there would be like men in black type
vans pulling up to your [ __ ]
warehouse okay and they would be smiling
but they'd have that look where they're
looking right through the back of your
head and at first they try to pay you
off and buy the [ __ ] patent and if
you didn't sell it to him
they would move to the next face and you
would somehow mysterious like the the
the urban myth with that guy Stan Lee
mayor's basically he was in a diner
he stood up said my god they've poisoned
me he walked out in the parking lot and
dropped dead shortly thereafter his card
in with the invention and it disappeared
and now his brother's trying to find out
what's got what happened to him which he
never will this is probably one of the
craziest podcasts I've ever done am I
freaking you guys out good all right
painters are coming here soon let's see
if I got time for a couple of advice
things
how about a question hey Bill big thanks
to you big thanks big thank you to your
parents for reproducing you for
reproducing and making me is what yeah I
think you're trying to say reproducing
me did they make it they make another
[ __ ] me what is your take on [ __ ] ISM
of
Sharon Tweed I don't know who that is oh
Shannon Tweed she and kiss frontman gene
Simmons were on The Joy Behar show and
she has finally reached her breaking
point with her wandering wiener with his
wandering wiener
she's been his girlfriend for almost two
decades she knew and accepted his group
sex lifestyle this whole time now that
the kids are out of the house it seems
like she had these grand illusions that
she could make gene Simmons a one-woman
man
and is publicly acting out whenever he
mentions the sex he's had with horror
number 999 or 1000 is this just like a
broad or what yours in Christ
Eric s oh then he says PS if I hear this
on the podcast i'll donate $49 dude you
don't need to bribe me keep your [ __ ]
money
anyways what is my take on this it's
just a show
it's just a show she's she's playing the
part she's acting like she's outraged
they're trying to have these media
moments where she flips the [ __ ] out cuz
they're trying to get people to watch
the show okay
gene Simmons is not a good-looking man
he's actually a bizarre-looking
man and I think he he doesn't even have
the decency to use Grecian formula I
think he is just using straight-up shoe
polish kiss has an inability to write a
good song from the jump which is why
they have to wear all the makeup and
have fire coming out of their balls it's
the Madonna thing it's like if Madonna
could actually sing and write a [ __ ]
song to which she really have to roll
around the floor like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
with half a [ __ ] lip hanging out
hanging out
would she I don't think she would so
what do I think this is a complete media
stunt and I think gene Simmons is an
unbelievably insecure human being that
he has to walk around talking about how
many [ __ ] women he's banged you know
and actually I mean honestly what
wouldn't you at what point do you stop
counting you know
878 does he have a little diary I don't
know I don't I don't understand the
whole thing but as far as like his girl
going on there I mean let's just say
that she actually loves this guy and
she's actually a functioning human being
I think she's an unbelievable trooper
and there's something [ __ ] wrong with
her like why would you stay with
somebody like that who's just been
completely unfaithful unless you just
you just have you've worked it out which
is I think she has it's a complete
business thing she wants to be taken
care of he does so now they have a new
reality show out cuz God knows who gives
a [ __ ] about a 2011 kiss album coming
out and then having to walk out and
tight leather pants with their giant
[ __ ] heads nobody cares nobody if I'm
just trying to piss off kiss fans I
don't give a [ __ ] okay I know the KISS
Army gives a [ __ ]
but the KISS Army alone is not enough to
keep a show on the air so what they have
to do is go on and just do this big
media stunt where she's finally putting
her her foot down after he bangs mm
woman of his [ __ ] career so uh that's
just that's just a [ __ ] media stunt
all right advice oh there's the painters
all right I gotta go you guys were
hanging I'm gonna put this on hold here
hold on hold on all right false alarm
he's down the street at Home Depot yeah
I got a couple things I got a bike I
don't know what the hell I was talking
about yeah it's just a media stunt they
just it's just all for the [ __ ] show
you know I mean what what actual
relationship would play that out on
television that's that's just [ __ ]
bizarre I've seen the Billboard as I
Drive down Sunset you know you know he
wants to rock she's ready to roll you
get it huh he still wants to [ __ ] around
but you guys love it it's [ __ ] Green
Acres that's all it is you know he's
from the city she's from the country he
wants to [ __ ] she wants him to be
faithful
there's your conflict that's basically
when you sell a TV show they always go
well how are we gonna get
you know five seasons out of this how do
we keep this going there's got it we
need more conflict between the
characters so there you go they have the
conflict it's complete horseshit
and the show's gonna stink
Jess I can't watch gene Simmons he's
unbelievably insecure guy and then he
overcompensates it with a massive
[ __ ] ego and it's uncomfortable to
watch how a man who looks like that I
mean if I looked like you know what he
looks like he actually looks like the
male version of that broad that [ __ ]
Schwarzenegger bank they have the same
exact [ __ ] head you know that
Transylvania looking [ __ ] head like
you know like how even like a vampire
kind of needs like a butler you know and
it's always some [ __ ] weird looking
somebody with like I like a hunchback
that's what he looks like
anyways let's let's do one quick advice
thing bill I know you probably won't
have any advice for this problem as I'm
probably just [ __ ] but maybe if I type
it out I will feel better Jesus Christ
look how [ __ ] long this is sometimes
I think people do this on purpose
because they know I'm not good at
reading out loud although I feel I've
gotten better anyways my dog staring at
me we're gonna go on a hike later you
want to go outside
yes you do all right hang on a second so
about five years ago I was living with
my folks and working an hour away from
home saving money to move I met a girl
that was really hot and I thought we had
similar interests okay there's a major
red flag when you said I thought the sex
was great
blah blah blah I started to realize that
she was a bit of a jackass but I wasn't
quite as smart as I am now so I stayed
with her for a while of course you did
she's hot she's also a single mom oh
Jesus and just waiting tables all right
- did this actually happen or is this
like a country song I met this girl she
was really beautiful worked down at the
diner and she had a kid I don't know how
to read so that's as good as I can do
[Music]
honey why don't we see the street when
we drive the car did you sell the
floorboards for more meth
I'll punch you in the stomach I don't
need another kid let's go smoke some
meth with a cop um anyways she comes to
me one day and asked me to co-sign a
loan so she can go to mechanic school
and get a job fixing cars oh uh uh she
jumping on the other side of the fence
here don't mean to be stereotypical she
said none of her family had any credit
and that that they couldn't cosign like
a total dumbass I co-signed her loan I
told her that I would help her but she
would have to pay it all back and I
wouldn't help and I wouldn't help her
make any of the missed payments oh Jesus
Christ and your name is on it so where's
her [ __ ] motivation they're her
credits already [ __ ] cuz she needs you
to co-sign the loan so she's basically
on a sinking ship
that weighs way more than your ship you
have a you have a little rowboat and you
just tied it to the [ __ ] Titanic so
what do you thinks gonna happen
I'm gonna guess everybody's he's gonna
go under - time goes on we stay friends
and I move out of town she dates other
guys I date tons of girls blah blah blah
oh so I guess the relationship ended I'm
finally getting my life together a few
years later with a great new job I've
paid off my car
dude this is AMA good and I'm finished
paying off my college loan and I start
getting calls from the bank over 50
bucks that she didn't pay before some
deferment kicks in because she is back
in school again I sent her a message on
Facebook
what so the whole world can see or he
sent a message okay
telling her I don't want my credit
[ __ ] up and I try to call her -
amazingly she changed her number she
stops answering my facebook messages and
deletes me there now see sir the one
from before this is just like a woman
right here used her [ __ ] to suck this
guy in to vacuum some money out of his
[ __ ] wallet and now she's walking
away like the femme fatale she is it's
been a few months and the bank was
calling me every day now they are saying
they will take money out of my paycheck
if I don't pay up I got a letter a day
ago saying I owe them $15,000 and I have
to respond in a month I know I signed a
piece of paper so I don't really have
any recourse I was stupid for trying to
help her better her life and I think
she's just trying to [ __ ] me over even
though she told me plenty of times that
that wasn't her attention I get so
[ __ ] angry thinking about this dude I
I feel for you man
I I mean I can't imagine the thoughts
that you're having please don't act on
any of them the stress of having alone
over my head that doesn't benefit me in
the least the fact that my credit might
be [ __ ] and mess up my future plans
the fact that I was dumb enough to try
and help somebody and it's just fueling
this rage this rage I feel to women for
being lazy manipulating sacks of [ __ ] as
much as I trash women and I like doing
it because I think it's funny because it
doesn't seem to happen on television
they're always shown as victims rather
than this type of thing it really is a
particular type of woman you know they
say a good man's hard to find it's the
same thing with the woman what can I do
let them suck money out of my bank
account for a decade until I pay him
back file for bankruptcy
how how would that [ __ ] up my credit
would it even wipe out the debt I don't
have a lot of I don't have a lot decent
apartment a car maybe a thousand dollars
in the bank account and being unemployed
for a while and finally getting a new
job after being unemployed for a while
and finally get a new job sorry for the
long email love your podcasts all right
dude I totally feel for you I know I was
breaking your balls up there I didn't
realize how this thing was going to end
Jesus Christ what can you do man I would
try to maybe try to go legally at her so
she just can't walk away which is going
to cost you more money the last thing I
would do is don't let this just don't
let it get to the point where they put
it to a collection agency because it's
gonna [ __ ] your credit if it's a $50
payment whatever is I would start making
the payments and then I would try to
take some sort of legal action against
her that's what I would do but in the
long run if you declare bankruptcy
you're gonna put yourself behind the
eight-ball I know it sucks but a fifth
$15,000
what are the payments on that there's
got to be 100 and change I have no idea
I would just you kind of got to pay it
but I would definitely try to go as much
as you can go after her legally and at
the very least drag her ass into court
but yeah and is really isn't a woman
thing because I've I've done this [ __ ]
before I remember I used to share I used
to share this rehearsal space to play
drums and like an idiot I came into some
money and I paid ahead like three four
months just so I wouldn't have to deal
with it because it was kind of a random
bill where it wasn't I didn't pay the
actual rehearsal space I was paying this
other guy so I gave this guy like 500
bucks for you know like I don't know how
many months and of course all of a
sudden like a month and a half later the
rehearsal space we lose the rehearsal
space and this guy who at any moment
when I owed him money and I was like hey
where are you he would immediately
return my texts he just completely
disappeared off the face of the [ __ ]
earth and never gave me my money back
and like the amount of [ __ ] people
who will do that to you and it really
has nothing to do with male or female
it's just people that they're [ __ ]
dirt bags their [ __ ] dirt bags which
brings me back to the [ __ ] oil
companies if someone would do this [ __ ]
over this amount of [ __ ] money I had
jizz on her I know I saw I just really
wish I could explain after my points
intelligently cuz I really think that
I'm right the dumbest things I've ever
said all right that's the podcast for
this week congratulations to the Boston
Bruins I I can't believe you won the
Stanley Cup in at some point I got to
get my ass to Boston I got to see it
I've never seen it never been up close
to it and went to the Hockey Hall of
Fame I guess it's there for a period of
time and I've never seen it and I'm
actually blown away and like I said my
condolence to the Vancouver Canucks fans
that that was an unbelievable kick in
the [ __ ] hockey balls to have to go
through that but obviously you shouldn't
have burned down your city and I know
most of the people up there didn't do it
and I know 90% of the people don't
condone that type of
behavior but uh I would like to know
people of Vancouver people in Montreal
you stuck-up snobs why do you guys burn
down your [ __ ] cities over sporting
events what are you really upset about
that's what I want to know because I
want to forward it to Michael Moore so
the next time he tries to make you guys
out like it's like The Truman Show up
there he can maybe have a little more
information and stop making movies that
are as ridiculously to the left as
foxnews is to the right okay that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves
I will talk to you next week I'll do it
I don't know what the [ __ ] am I gonna
watch in sports this is the worst time
of year for me as a sports fan the
excitement of the NBA files and the NHL
Stanley Cup files brings you to an
absolute height and then boom it's over
it's talking appalled virzi we were
laughing about that [ __ ] you go from
this undelete you [ __ ] see Dwayne
Wade you see Dirk Nowitzki did you
[ __ ] see this did you see that did
you [ __ ] game seven bro and you
losing your mind texting and then all of
a sudden comes to abrupt halt and it's a
ball one I'll tell you this kid just
came up from her she's a hell of a
prospect he's one of the best second
baseman that the Milwaukee Brewers have
had in quite some time
Oh fouled back
101 it's uh it's Hat day coming up this
Thursday and now they might not even
have a football season here's my
prediction if they don't have an NFL
football season college football is
gonna have it's gonna I think it could
finally blow up in cities like Boston
which is not a profession sauna college
football town well we will get into BC
every once in a while but would you
we're just not into it because we have
all these professional teams that are
winning all the [ __ ] championships
sorry I got a gloat a little bit I think
I've been rough quite a [ __ ]
gentleman you know Jesus Christ a couple
of things do you realize if [ __ ] if
our defensive back guest of the right
way could have knocked down that pass
that could have been another Super Bowl
you know if those NBA refs a couple
years back didn't decide to call 9000
fouls on the Celtics and two on the
Lakers that we might even had another
[ __ ] NBA championship we might have
[ __ ] won nine but I'll take my seven
go Cleveland
let's go Padres let's go brewers I'm
[ __ ] rooting for all you I'm done as
I am I am [ __ ] retired i-i've for at
least 15 years not 15 for like 10 I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm stepping back for 10
I don't give a [ __ ] you know something I
think at this point I'm so [ __ ] happy
even the Jets winning a Super Bowl
wouldn't bug me
alright let's not go that far alright
guys I'll talk to you I'll talk to you
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
coppy understand that this border areas
pretty clear with us
[Music]